The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK, so
this is a review session
open to questions on homework.
Open to questions on
topics in the exam
that's coming tomorrow.
This morning I wrote down
what the four questions would
be about, and I'm glad I did.
I never-- should have done
this many times before.
So you would know
exactly and get down
to seeing what
those problems are.
And of course the
matrices called K,
and A transpose C A are going to
appear probably more than once.
So, open for any questions.
About any topic whatsoever.
Please.
Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: The
fourth question on the exam?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: I'm glad
you used that word, fun.
Yes.
That's exactly what I mean.
Section 2.4, and
they are fun, yeah.
So I drew by hand a little
graph with nodes and edges.
And you want to be able to
take that first basic step.
So the first step,
which is as far as we
got by last Wednesday, the
first lecture on Section 2.4,
was just creating the matrix
A, understanding A transpose A,
and of course there's more to
understand about A transpose A.
Actually, why don't
we take one second.
Suppose I have a graph
with six nodes, let's say.
Can you imagine a
graph with six nodes?
And every node connected
to every other node.
So however many
edges that would be.
Actually, my grandson just
got that question on his exam.
He was told there were l islands
with a flight from every island
to every other island,
and he was asked
how many flights that makes.
So I sent him the answer.
But I was very happy
with his reply.
He said "that's
exactly what I got."
So, what do you know.
It seems to work.
So anyway.
Suppose we had, how
many nodes did I say?
Six?
OK.
So we have like a
six-node-- So n is six,
and it's a complete
graph, this is really just
to start us off talking
about some of these problems.
So the matrix A, so I
think it would be 15,
where did I come up
with that number 15?
And is it right, actually?
Yes.
This is one way, would be the
first node has five edges going
out and then the
second node would
have four additional edges,
and three and two and one.
And five, four, three,
two, one add to 15.
What would be the shape
of A in that case?
So it has a row for every edge.
So 15 by 6, I think.
OK, and I could create
A transpose A just
to have a look at it.
So it would be, what shape
would A transpose A be?
Six by six.
Symmetric, of course.
Will it be singular
or non-singular?
Singular.
Singular, because we
haven't grounded any nodes.
We've got all these nodes,
all these edges, nothing.
We haven't taken
out that column;
when I reduce it to five by
five, then it'll be invertible.
But six by six, so what will
be the diagonal of this?
This'll be now six by six,
the size will be six by six.
And what will go on the diagonal
is the degrees of every node.
That means how many
edges are coming in,
and what number is that?
Five.
So I'll have five down the
diagonal, and what else,
what will be off the diagonal?
Minus, a whole lot of
minus ones, a minus one
above and below for every edge.
And since we have a
complete graph, how many
minus ones have we got?
All of them.
All minus ones.
So all minus ones
and all minus ones.
That's fine to cross over
if you need to, sure.
I'm not sure what else
to say about that matrix.
Well, it's not invertible.
Now let's take the next step
which, I'm now going probably
beyond the exam part.
Just really to get us started,
I ground the sixth node.
Suppose I ground
node number six,
that wipes out a row and
a column, is that right?
So I'm now left with
a five by five matrix.
It still has all minus
ones there and there,
but now it's five
by five, now it
is what kind of a matrix,
what are its properties?
Square, obviously, symmetric
obviously, and now invertible.
Positive definite, OK.
So it's fives there and now
I would have four minus ones.
Let's just write them in here.
Typical row, now, in
this five by five matrix
would have four minus ones and
of course more here, and more
here, and one there.
And symmetric.
All I want to say
is that that matrix,
we don't often write down
the inverses of matrices,
but that one I think we could.
I think we could actually, and
it's a little bit interesting
to know, for that special
matrix, everything about it.
We could find its eigenvalues,
its determinant, its pivots,
the whole works for that matrix.
And that's one page
of the book, maybe
at the end of
Section 2.4, I think,
comes more detail
about that matrix.
So in a way that special guy
is like our special K matrix,
-1, 2, -1, for
second differences.
Somehow this is taking,
all nodes are connected.
Instead of in a line, springs
in a line, points in a line,
we now have everybody
connected to everybody.
So this is sort of the
special matrix when
everybody is
connected to everybody
and we could learn all
about that particular one.
But then, of course, if
some edges are not in then
some zeroes will
appear off the diagonal
in the adjacency matrix part.
The degrees will drop a little
if we're missing some edges
and the inverse will be
not some simple expression.
Anyway, that's to
get us started.
So that's really where the last
lecture, Friday, brought us
to this point.
And I'll take this chance
to add in the block matrix
just because I think of
it as quite important.
So for this case,
C is the identity.
So I would have the identity up
in that block, A in that block,
A transpose in this block.
That would be my mixed
method matrix, you could say.
My saddle point matrix.
It starts out very
positive definite.
But it ends up
negative definite.
And that's typical of
mixed methods, when
both unknowns, the currents
as well as the potentials,
are included in the system.
So A transpose w, that was
f, I think, and this is b.
I just mentioned that again,
it was in Friday's lecture
and it's in the book
but I would just
want to say I
often refer to this
as the fundamental problem
of numerical analysis,
is how do you solve that system.
And of course elimination
is one way to do it.
When I eliminate w,
that will lead me
to the equation A
transpose Au equals,
I think it'll be, there'll be an
A transpose b minus f, I think.
C being the identity there.
So that's the mixed method,
this is the displacement method,
and this is the popular one.
Because it's all at once.
But people think
about this one, too.
So that's like saying again
what was in Friday's lecture
and will be used going forward.
OK, that was just
to get us started.
Now, please let's
have some questions.
We need another question.
Who else?
Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: The
first on the homework.
What number was that?
Section 2.2, number six?
About the trapezoidal rule?
Yes.
OK, now I did speak about that
a little in the last review
session, but can I just say
a couple words more about it
here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
What's it asking?
Yes.
People often ask me
that about my problems.
I don't know.
You can't read my mind?
You should.
OK, so the point is that
for special differential
equations-- So let me just
summarize what we did there.
So this we did before, but
I didn't do everything.
So what we did before was point
out that the system du/dt =
Au conserves
energy. u squared, u
of time-- for all
time, u of time
squared stays constant if A
transpose equals minus A. OK,
essentially you
take the derivative,
it's got two terms because
we've got a product there,
a product rule.
The derivative will be,
one term will involve A,
the other term will
involve A transpose,
and if our matrix has this
antisymmetric property,
those terms will cancel;
the derivative will be zero,
and that'll mean that
this is a constant.
OK, so that's the
differential equation.
Now, the question was about
the difference equation.
So we're taking the
trapezoidal rule
and we want to show that
u_n squared stays constant
for the trapezoidal rule.
And so what that means, in
other words, is step by step,
u_(n+1), and I could
write it u_(n+1) squared,
but the other way to write that
and the way we have to work
with it is that, is the same.
Now, that was just an identity,
that's just the meaning.
Now, I want to show
that that's the key.
That's what we
would want to prove.
That the trapezoidal rule copies
the property of constant energy
of the differential equations.
And of course, you know
that in oscillating springs
when there's no source, no
forces coming from outside,
the total energy
will stay constant.
And you could think of
many other situations.
You have a spacecraft, where
you've turned off the engines.
It's just going there,
it's possibly rotating.
So there you've got
angular velocity
included in the total energy.
Important fact, if energy stays
constant you want to know it.
And you're very happy
if the finite difference
method copies it.
OK, so then it was just
a question of-- Here
we took derivatives
to do that one.
Here we're going to be
playing with differences,
and my suggestion
was that the good way
to get it was to
take that vector
times the trapezoidal equation
and show that this turned out
to-- The trapezoidal equation
is something equals zero,
and you hope, and it takes a
few lines of jiggling around,
that when you do that
you'll get the difference,
you get exactly this.
You get u_(n+1) transpose
u_(n+1) minus u_n transpose
u_n.
That's the goal.
We know that the
trapezoidal equation--
maybe I move everything onto
one side so I have something
equals zero.
Then my trick is take
that vector equation,
multiply by that, play
around with those terms
and you'll get this.
So, since that is
zero, this is zero.
And that's exactly what
our goal was to prove.
So it's just in
the jiggling around
and maybe we don't want to
take the full time because I'll
post that.
Actually, I may post some
of these solutions even
before the quiz.
And therefore before
the homework is due,
just because this particular
homework, as I say,
is not-- The graders
are just going
to be so busy with
all the quizzes.
This is for learning.
Now, here's the one thing
you want to learn out
of this messy computation.
You also have a term,
you'll also find a term U_n,
when you just do
this mechanically,
you'll find a u_(n+1)
transpose u_n,
and you'll find a u_n
transpose u_(n+1),
and they'll come in
with opposite signs.
That'll be when you've
plugged in the fact
that A transpose equals minus
A, and all I wanted to do
is ask you, what does
that term amount to?
Because that term will show up.
One way or another.
And what does it equal?
Zero.
Everybody should know that.
That's the one
thing, that you have
to add to just
mechanically computing,
is the fact that the dot product
of that vector with that,
v transpose w is the same
as w transpose v. So,
it's good to just call attention
to the easy things that
are like that.
Why is that?
That's because both sides,
this is equal to what? v_1*w_1,
v_2*w_2, v_3*w_3,
component by component.
And this is w_1*v_1.
But we're just talking
numbers at that point.
So the numbers of v_1 times
w_1 are certainly the same
as w_1 times v_1.
Every component by component,
they're exactly the same
and of course then the
dot products are the same.
So that's the fact which
for this v and that w,
make the term go away,
that's still sitting there.
Other terms go away
because of this property.
Having written that
and recognizing
that we have Fourier
stuff coming up
in the last third of the course,
where we have complex numbers.
I have to say that if when
I have complex vectors,
do you know about those?
The dot product, or
the length squared,
if this was a vector of complex,
with possibly complex numbers,
I wouldn't take the
length squared just
by adding up these squares.
Suppose my-- Yes, I'm really
anticipating weeks ahead,
but suppose my
vector was [1,  i].
What's the length of
that particular vector v?
Well, if I do v transpose
v, what do I get?
For v equals [1, i], what does
v transpose v turn out to be?
Zero.
One squared plus
i squared is zero.
No good.
So obviously some rule
has to change a little bit
to get the correct number.
The correct length squared,
I would rather expect two.
The size of that squared plus
the size of that squared.
So I don't want to
square i, I want
to square its absolute value.
And the way to do
that is conjugate one
of the two things.
Now I'm taking [1, i], and on
the other side I have [1, -i]
and that gives me
the two that I want.
So what I'm doing, when
I've got complex vectors
then I would really
do that, and now that
is not the same as that.
Right.
Yeah.
If in one case if I'm
doing the conjugate of v
and the other case it's
the conjugate of w,
then I've got a
complex conjugate.
OK, that's a throwaway
comment that just is relevant
because it keeps us focused
for a moment on the real case,
where we do have equals.
Now, I don't know if that
was sufficient answer?
It wasn't a complete
answer because I
didn't do the manipulations,
but the solutions
posted should show you those.
And, of course, you can organize
them a little different.
OK, good for that one.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: The
other two terms here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yes.
You couldn't cancel them.
Well, I recommend just, that's
how the best mathematics is
done, right?
You want zero,
you just X it out.
Anyway.
Let me leave the posted
solutions to be a hint
and come back to it.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
The next problem was?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh, yes.
OK, that one I spoke a
little bit about, but now
let me read from the
problem set that I got.
I noticed that was quite brief.
Oh, to find that actual angle?
Somehow that's a little
interesting, isn't it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: To tell the
truth, I meant numerically.
I meant, what's the
point of that question.
The point is we're trying to
solve, this isn't a big deal.
But it was just if we're
using this trapezoidal method,
the beauty of that, exactly
what our thing proves,
is-- Here the constant
energy surface is the circle.
The point of the trapezoidal
method for this simple equation
u''+u=0, which amounted to the
equation uv' equals something
like, our a matrix
was antisymmetric.
So it fit perfectly
in that problem,
and if we started on the
circle we stay on the circle.
And if I take 32 steps I come
back pretty closely to here,
and I just thought it might be
fun to figure out numerically,
with MATLAB or a
calculator or something,
we take an angle, theta, is that
what the problem asks, and then
come around here to
32 theta, and 32 theta
will not be exactly 2pi.
But darned close.
Because you could see in
the figure in the book
it wasn't too far off.
So the question was,
what is that theta?
So I think that the
formula turned out
to be that each step multiplied
by this one plus i delta t,
or h, on two divided by one
minus i delta t over two.
And when you plug in
delta t to be 2pi over 32,
so that's the, what
did I say, that's
the tangent of
theta or something?
Sorry, I've forgotten the
way the problem was put.
Oh, it's e to the i theta, yeah.
What's the main point
about that complex number?
When you look at
that complex number
what's the most
essential thing you see?
That it, yeah, tell me again.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Magnitude one, great.
It's a number divided by
its complex conjugate,
so it's a number
of magnitude one.
And now tell me, if you see
a complex number of magnitude
one, what jumps to mind?
What form do you
naturally put it in?
e^(i*theta).
Every complex number of absolute
value one is just beautifully
written in the form e^(i*theta).
That complex number is some
point on the unit circle,
so there it is.
Right there, there
it is, e^(i*theta).
With that-- theta
is negative there,
because we're going
the wrong way.
No big deal.
Maybe here theta's positive.
I've forgotten, so
I won't try to go
either the clockwise or the
counterclockwise way around.
So, if I wanted to figure out
what theta was and plugged
in these things, let's see.
So that's pi over 32, delta t
over two would be pi over 32,
and this guy would be its
conjugate. pi over 32,
and then in this
solution that'll
be plugged on the homework
this will be, I think maybe,
maybe the theta comes out to
be, it's kind of cool actually,
twice the arc tangent of
pi over 32 or something.
I didn't know that.
But that'll be in the
solutions for you to check.
So now, why do I like
e^(i*theta) so much?
Because now I could tell
you what this point is,
after you've done it 32 times.
What angle have you reached?
This is the crunch line of using
complex numbers, e^(i*theta),
is that they're absolutely
great for taking powers.
If I take the 32nd power of
x plus iy, I'm lost, right.
x plus iy to the 32nd
power starts out x^32,
ends up i^32 y^32, with
horrible stuff in between.
But what is the 32nd
power of e^(i*theta)?
e^(i*32theta).
Just that angle 32 times
exactly as we've drawn it.
So that's the point
e^(i*32theta).
OK, and therefore if we now
know what theta is, so yeah.
So it must be pretty near
2pi, but not exactly.
I guess that's about right.
In fact, having got
this far, the tangent
of a very small angle
is approximately what?
It's approximately
the angle, right?
The sine of a very small angle
is approximately the angle.
The cosine is approximately one.
The tangent is
approximately the angle.
So this, 32 theta,
is 32 times two times
approximately the angle.
And what answer do you get?
2pi.
Which makes sense.
So you could say what the
trapezoidal method has done
is to replace the exact
angle by the inverse tangent
approximately.
That's sort of nice.
In this example you
can get as far as that
and you could actually
find out how near that is.
And, by the way, how near
would I expect it to be?
I would expect it,
so what do we know
about the trapezoidal method
without having proved it?
It's second order
accurate, right?
If it was first
order accurate, I
would expect it to miss by
something of the size of theta.
Maybe a fraction of theta.
But being second
order accurate, I'm
expecting it to
miss by something
of size theta squared.
So it would be pretty
near zero, right.
And actually, another way I
know it's around-- So the error
would be something
like, it would have a 32
squared in the denominator.
And I've just thought of
another way to see that.
We just said that the
first term in the arc
tangent of a small angle,
theta, of a small angle,
alpha, whatever that is, pi over
32, the first term in the arc
tangent is?
The angle.
That's what we just said.
Then, do you know
what would come next?
Now we're looking at the error.
So that of a very small
angle will start theta,
and I want to ask you about
how many theta squareds
and theta cubes.
You're seeing what you can do
with paper and pencils type
stuff.
Here's my main question, how
many theta squareds in there?
You want to make a guess?
A mathematician's
favorite number, zero.
Right, there will be no
theta squared terms in.
That's an odd function, so
I'm expecting only odd powers
and therefore I won't
be surprised to see
theta cubed come up first.
And then when I
multiply by the 32,
I get the theta squared that
I guessed we would have.
OK, once again I'll stop there
because that's very narrow path
to be following but
it shows you how.
You know, there's
a lot of room still
for what you can do
with paper and pencil
to understand a model problem.
And then the computer
would tell us
about a serious problem of
following the solar system
for a million years.
OK, another totally
different question, if I can.
Yes, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah, sure.
PROFESSOR STRANG: 2.4.1, right.
A mistake in the book.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Or in the, yeah.
It's quite possible.
OK, there's a printed
error in the graph.
Yeah.
So in numbering the
edges, well let's
blame it on the printer, right?
Not the author.
OK, so the diagonal edge,
that five probably was
intended to be a three, yeah.
Thank you.
So we'll catch that
in the next printing.
And you recognize that always,
numbering the edges and nodes
is a pretty
arbitrary thing, it's
just if we number differently
that just reorders
the rows of the matrix.
If we number the
edge differently,
it'll reorder the rows and
it'll reorder rows and columns
of A transpose A. So it won't
make a serious difference
in the matrix.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Do you
want to go back to this guy?
OK.
AUDIENCE: So if you have
an anti-symmetric matrix,
does it follow that the
eigenvectors used are
perpendicular?
PROFESSOR STRANG: This
is a good question.
This guy, way up here,
with this property,
AUDIENCE: The eigenvectors
are perpendicular?
PROFESSOR STRANG: The
eigenvectors are perpendicular.
Yes, yeah.
So we have, there's this, like,
the nobility among matrices
are the ones with
perpendicular eigenvectors.
So that includes
symmetric matrices,
this is a good and
straightforward point.
So these are the good matrices.
Symmetric matrices.
A transpose equals
A. Their eigenvalues
lie on the real line.
And these are all
perpendicular eigenvectors.
What about antisymmetric?
OK, that means A
transpose is minus A.
They also fall in this
noble family of matrices,
and where are their eigenvalues?
Pure imaginary, right up here.
Now do you want to know,
who else is in this family?
What's the other, this
is the complex plane;
there's one more piece
of the complex plane
that you know I'm going to put.
Which is?
What else to make that
complex plane look familiar,
it's going to have
the unit circle.
Every complex plane has got
to have the unit circle.
OK, so these guys went with
the, and now what do you think
goes with the, this will
be the matrices-- Can
I call them Q instead, because
I called them Q this morning.
Q transpose is Q inverse.
Q transpose Q, and they're
the orthogonal matrices.
So those matrices again,
beautiful matrices
in the best class.
And their eigenvalues
are on the unit circle.
And that would be--
Why don't I just show you why?
Because orthogonal
matrices, there
are not so many that are
really worth knowing.
So, let me take Qx=lambda*x,
and what is it that I want
to prove?
I want to prove that the
eigenvalues have absolute value
one.
That's the unit circle.
So how do I show
that the eigenvalues
have absolute value of one?
Let me take the dot
product with Qx transpose.
So both sides, I'll do Qx
transpose Qx and I'll do
lambda*x transpose
lambda*x, right?
Only these are complex.
I've got to take complex stuff.
OK.
I just took the length squared
of both sides, and kept in mind
the possibility that
this x and lambda
could be, and probably
will be, complex numbers.
Now, what do I have on the left?
Do you see it happening?
I get an x bar
transpose, what do I get?
Q transpose Qx on the left side.
That's the combination
I'm looking for.
For an orthogonal matrix.
Let's imagine the
matrix itself is real,
otherwise I would
just conjugate it.
What's nice about
that left side?
What fact am I going
to use about Q?
Q transpose Q is the identity.
So this thing is nothing
but x bar transpose x.
That's the length of x squared.
What have I got
on the right side?
I've got the length of x
squared times a number,
lambda bar times lambda squared.
It's there, now.
On the left side I have
the length of x squared.
On the right side
I have the length
of x squared times that
number, mod lambda squared.
Therefore, that
number has to be one
and the eigenvalues
are on the unit circle.
So, I've given you the three big
important classes of matrices
with perpendicular eigenvectors.
I think anybody
would wonder, OK,
what about other eigenvalues.
What's the condition for
perpendicular eigenvectors
that includes this.
And includes this.
And includes this,
and also allows
eigenvalues all over the place.
Would you like to
know that condition?
What the heck.
That condition, that
includes all these
is this, that A transpose times
A equals A times A transpose.
That's the test for
perpendicular eigenvectors.
A transpose commutes with A.
So this passes, of course.
This passes, of course.
This passes because both
sides are the identity,
and then some more
matrices pass also.
OK.
Is that alright?
You asked for some linear
algebra and you got it.
Now I'm ready, yes, thanks.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: 2.4.19.
Oh, let me look.
2.4.19.
Ah.
OK, yes, sorry and I should
have done better with that.
So one graphs that are
important are grids like this.
And we'll see them-- Two, three,
four, one, two, three, four.
That would be where--
These are the nodes.
So this is a grid.
I meant to draw them all
in, but I won't. n squared.
So n is six, and
I'd have 36 nodes.
And you can see
the edges in there.
So that's the graph
I have in mind.
And the reason that
problem is there
is that last year, I
think it was last year
or the year before, we spent
some time with figuring out
resistances and currents and
so on for these problems.
And we needed some
fast way to generate A,
because this matrix A is now,
what size is the matrix A?
It's got, I don't know how
many edges does it have?
One, two, three, four, five,
maybe 30 edges going across
and 30 coming down.
It'll be 60 by how many
columns in this matrix?
You know the answer
now and it's worth
knowing, for the quiz of course.
36.
OK.
Anyway, the class rebelled
about creating these matrices
and working with the matrices,
with 2,160 non-zeroes.
People were dropping the course.
So we needed a command that
would create A pretty quickly.
And so that's what
the book, and so this
was like the 18.085 command.
After we stumbled
around for a while,
we discovered that
a MATLAB command
called kron was a quick
way to create the matrix.
We'll see that when
we get to that point.
This is an important graph.
And it's closely connected
to Laplace's-- You remember
Laplace's--?
I'll just tell you.
Laplace's equation is this,
you have a second x derivative,
we know how to deal with those.
But it also has a
second y derivative.
So I'm really looking ahead
at the most important equation
of Chapter 3,
Laplace's equation.
And suppose I use
finite differences.
I want a matrix K_(2D) that
deals with this 2D problem.
And let me just say
what it would be.
At a typical point
this x derivative
is giving me a minus one,
a two and a minus one.
And the y derivative is
giving me a minus one
that moves this guy up
to four and minus one.
So instead of -1, 2,
-1 along a typical row,
we'll now have a four on the
diagonal and four minus one
in a certain pattern.
Anyway.
You'll see that, it's
interesting when we get to it.
That would show up in A
transpose A. So what I've said
here is what happens with
A transpose A. I guess
I'm hoping that you begin to
know these matrices, first
seeing them occasionally
in homeworks
and then in the lecture.
Good.
But that's looking ahead.
I needed some questions
that are like,
close to, really
on what we're doing
or what the quiz would do.
Any - thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh yes.
A little bit.
OK, yeah.
So I wrote down this
equation and what I'm writing
right there is the new part.
Sort of new, and I guess--
Equals some right hand side
f(x).
And the discrete version
will be an A transpose
C A equal a vector
f, maybe there
will be a delta x squared here.
OK.
I guess maybe, I
don't want to go far
but I want you to see that if
we have a coefficient c in here
it should show up there.
You could actually, it might be
reasonable to look at 3.1 just
to look slightly ahead
to see the parallels,
but you would get them right
without a lecture on it.
Your coefficient shows up in
the differential equation,
and it shows up on the
diagonal of C in the difference
equation.
I won't give a whole
lecture on that,
just to say that correspondence
is exactly the one we know.
A is a difference matrix.
Like the derivative.
C will be a diagonal
matrix, A transpose
will be whatever
that comes out to be.
And so you've seen
A transpose A,
but think again about
that difference--
And ask yourselves this.
I suggest, take c to be
one, get c out of there.
And just think, again, what is
the difference matrix A with
a boundary either
fixed-fixed or fixed-free,
those will be two different A's.
What are the A's for
fixed-fixed and for fixed-free?
This is what we were doing
at the very beginning
of the course.
So A is a first
difference matrix,
and A transpose A will
be the second difference.
So the A transpose A, of course,
I was doing A transpose A,
then the answer here
would be the matrix K
and the answer here would
be the matrix T. Or,
depending which end is free,
but we'd have one change.
That's A transpose A,
but now think about the A
that it came from.
So A will be, A
is the matrix that
takes differences
of the u's, and then
A transpose A takes
second differences.
Of all the questions
asked, this is
the one most
relevant for the exam
and for what we've done so far.
I've gone off onto topics
that we look ahead to,
but this is where we are.
So that matrix A is a
first difference matrix,
and then you put in the
boundary conditions.
OK.
There was another question.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Of number four?
Which number four in which?
Oh, in the quiz.
Oh yes, right.
Yes.
Did I tell you what
problem four was?
No.
I hope not.
OK problem four in the quiz.
It's about a delta function?
Yeah.
What do I know, what do
you want me to tell you?
So the delta, of
course, comes in
as, we've seen it, as the right
hand side of a differential
equation.
So it might be the right-hand
side even of this equation.
So if this equation was delta
of x, or x-1/2 or something.
I mean, the essential
thing is that when
delta's on the right side, that
gives you a drop in the slope.
Suppose I just have a first
order equation like d --
I'll call it z --
dz/dx = delta(x-a).
Yeah.
And suppose that I know
that z(0) starts at zero.
You've got to be able
to solve that equation,
so this is a useful
prep for that.
That would be a good equation
to know the solution to.
And what kind of
function is this?
What kind of a
function is z(x) there?
I just use the letter
z to have a new letter.
z(x) will be a step.
Right. z(x) will be
a step function, yes.
That's right.
OK, so the solution
is that at the point
a, which I'm presuming is beyond
zero, I come along at zero
and I step up.
Yep.
OK.
That would be a
picture of z(x), yeah.
So it's basic delta
function material
that I'm speaking about here.
So z jumps by one
and if z is a slope,
then the slope jumps
by one or drops by one,
depending on a plus
or a minus sign here.
The things that we've used
to deal with delta functions,
so that's what
Question 4b is about.
The drop in slope, or
the jumps, or whatever
happens when a delta function
shows up on the right side.
Good question.
Yep.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: 1.1.27.
Well.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh,
and then left a typo.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: Oh.
I'm sorry, OK.
1.1.27.
My copy isn't showing it.
Yeah.
I may have to punt
on that question.
Or do you want me to look at it?
OK, can you maybe just pass
that the book up, alright.
I'll try to read what
that question was.
OK.
Yeah, maybe this is
a question to answer.
This is probably the one
new question that got added.
OK, yeah.
Fair enough.
So this is continuing
the discussion
that you asked me to start here
about A, the first difference
matrix, OK.
So I'll go a little
more over that.
So in the book here,
this writes down
a matrix A_0, which is--
I'll discuss this matrix.
So there's a difference matrix.
You see what I mean by
a difference matrix,
if were to multiply it by
u, [u 0, u 1, u 2, u 3]
or something, I would
get differences, right?
I'd get u_1-u_0,
u_2-u_1, and u_3-u_2.
Good.
So that's A_0 times u.
Alright.
So that's a difference matrix.
What graph would that come from?
That's also the incidence
matrix of a very simple graph.
This is connecting
Chapter 1 with Chapter 2.
It would be a line of
springs, it would be a graph.
It's got edges and nodes.
It's got three edges,
so I've got three rows.
It's got four nodes so
I've got four columns.
Are the columns
independent here?
No, they never are.
The vector of all ones would
have differences of all zeroes.
So what would that, that
would be the difference
matrix for fixed?
Free?
Fixed, free, circular what
would that difference matrix
correspond to?
Everybody's saying it.
Say it a little louder just to.
Free-free.
That's a free-free problem,
because they're all in there.
We haven't knocked any out.
There are no boundary
conditions yet.
That's a free-free, so that
A_0 would be free-free.
OK.
I'll take one more case and
then I think we're at time.
Suppose it was fixed-fixed?
What would be the difference
matrix that would correspond
to, how would I
change that matrix
if my problem
became fixed-fixed?
So now I'm fixing that
u, I'm fixing that u,
in the mass spring case
I'm adding supports there.
How would that
change the matrix?
First and fourth, good.
Say it again?
First and fourth
columns would go.
So fixed-free would
then be three by two.
Free-free was three by four.
Yeah, I'm glad this
question came up
because this is the
right thing for you to be
thinking about in connection
with the recent question
you asked.
OK.
Maybe that's the
right place to stop,
because now you've asked
questions that are really
on target for what we've done,
and I hope useful to you.
OK, see you guys tomorrow
evening at 7:30 in 54-100, OK.